jessica is in texas hi Jessica welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hello hi what's
up I am calling because me my husband
actually husband introduced me to listen
to your pod and her podcast and I've
actually been listening to the past
three nights we've saved money we have
paid off four of our credit cards
working on three other ones we plan to
have them all paid off by February 1st
we are yes we are trying to buy our
first house at the end of the year close
to August September area the moment when
I'm running into issues yes somebody has
an issue my husband and his parents live
with us because his mother had multiple
heart attacks Lester life and a stepdad
has early signs of dementia and then we
have three kids so we were pre-approved
for 450 on the house phone I honestly am
scared to pay for a house that's 450 so
their goal was to pay off in 10 years
and it scares the living devil out of me
sounds like maybe 400 at 350 is more
realistic but I know we're going to need
a bigger house than what we already have
now so I just wanted to get some advice
like how should we move in the process
should we just buy Sybil and spend the
four hundred thousand four hundred fifty
thousand on the house loan we make
roughly 150 if my husband works overtime
which he does it will be 175 by the end
of 2020 okay and you're out of debt
February 1st then you have your
emergency fund in place of three to six
months of expenses next that is baby
step 3 yeah then you save your down
payment and that puts you into a
position to buy late summer early fall
correct well we have our car loans and
they have to be paid off before you buy
yes so that's our goal I have a bonus
coming in
it's going to pay one of our cars off
and they show ru debt-free february 1st
or not
no just credit card oh not here
when will the card and the my husband's
truck will be paid off in February
probably March I don't overextend
yourself or probably March but my car
won't be paid off for another maybe two
years I'm scared I don't want to say you
don't buy a house and take a car's paid
off so pay off the car first you need to
be debt-free completely debt-free okay
how much do you owe on your freaking car
my car I owe three thousand we just got
it okay so why don't you just pay it off
why does it take two years you make one
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars a year mm-hmm let's just pay it
off no that's more thinking but I'm just
scared that we're over ourselves how
would you overextend yourself you're
broke and buying cars you can't afford
you're already overextended I don't want
you I don't want you to pay it off and
not have money for your house payment
your current house payment or food or
something like that but you need that
car is in your debt snowball you list
all of your debts smallest to largest
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one attack the little one in
the next one then the next one and then
the next one it sounds like the order of
the three debts as credit cards to the
his car to your cars now that your car
is the largest debt of the three okay
and gonna attack it in that order and so
now you're not buying a house until this
time next year mm-hmm because you need
to get this car paid off and you need to
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then you need to
save your down payment for your house at
that point let's go back to your
original question once your debt free
once you have your emergency fund in
place and once you have your down
payment then the most house you should
buy the absolute maximum is after you
put your down payment on down whatever
your loan balance is the payment on a
15-year fixed rate
shouldn't
be more than one-fourth of your
take-home pay your husband have money
coming out of his check right now for
401k he does yeah you should stop that
temporarily until you achieve these
goals temporarily
so let's knock the dead out get the
emergency fund get the down payment and
then buy a house where the payment is no
more than one-fourth of your take-home
pay on a 15-year fixed-rate and let's go
that way and if you do all that you're
going to be fine but that's gonna be
this time next year you're not gonna be
able do all of that by fall now that we
introduced the $20,000 car payment into
this equation so you need to be
debt-free if you buy a house with that
you are asking for trouble I want you to
buy a house but I want it to be a
blessing and not a curse as you said I
don't want you over extended I don't
want you stretched by your house and as
soon as you move in a house with that
Murphy will show up if it can go wrong
it will he will bring his three cousins
broke desperate and stupid and this
house will become everything is gonna
get messed up this house is going to
become a problem one of those relative
early relatives you're taking care of
gonna have some kind of a medical crisis
all kinds of stuffs gonna happen as soon
as you buy a house while you're broke
never buy a house while you're broke it
makes you broker that's why they call
them brokers